and the big news today kind of dropped
out of the blue shireen there was a near
miss a few weeks ago in camp for 49ers
cornerback richard sherman he had some
sort of lower leg injury that had
everyone concerned he promptly came back
to practice we never heard anything more
about it and i don't know where he got
the injury that he now has is the same
thing was it exaggerated whatever the
case may be or aggravated exaggerated
you know
he now he's on injury reserve out of the
blue
like that into preserve for richard
sherman which is kind of stunning
and this is a tool the teams can use
this year
because of the roster flexibility rules
that let you put a guy on ir for only
three weeks we're going to see more guys
on ir than ever before
and if they drop a guy on ir by
wednesday they never have to tell us
what the issue is they never have to
disclose anything in an injury report
about whether it's
lower body upper body is it ankle is it
hip is it whatever did he practice can
he practice is just he's on ninja
reserve and he'll be back at some point
and that's all we know
mike i haven't gotten out of this oh my
gosh he's on injured reserve type thing
and it's only three weeks now and and i
know a lot of coaches hope that they
maintain this going forward in 2021 and
they can bring these guys back and they
only bring it back once but i think it's
a great tool that teams can use but i've
got to get out of that okay it's only
for three weeks but you know with
richard sherman i had to look up his age
it feels like to me that he's played
forever and he's only 32 but in his
first six seasons he played all 16 games
and now he's had these little knicks and
injuries and different things that have
happened he played nine games in 2017
and 14 and 2018 and 15 last year and now
he's gonna miss at least three games
this year and he he still is one of the
best cornerbacks in the nfl but he's got
to stay on the field and and the 49ers
unfortunately for them have had a lot of
these injuries early this season
and what i said wasn't 100 accurate i
said we know he's on into reserve and
he's coming back at some point we don't
know that he's coming back at some point
that's the beauty of it they can put a
guy on ir and never bring him back all
we know is after three weeks the guy can
come back and this is all part of the
covet 19 protocol to make it easier for
teams to have
53 healthy guys on the roster so you're
not carrying someone on the roster that
does have a short-term injury that is
going to be back sooner rather than
later but you don't want to put on into
preserve because under the normal
circumstances it's eight weeks of a
minimum absence and you can only do it
for three it was going to be three guys
this year it started as one then it
became two now it was going to be three
now it's everybody anybody you want
is gone for a minimum of three weeks and
they don't have to say anything to us
it's the way the vikings handled the
neil hunter hey coach what's wrong with
danielle hunter one of the best
defensive ends in football he's got a
tweak he's got a tweet that's all we
heard all know all of all of august and
then last week just as they're getting
ready to issue the first injury report
he's put on ir they still haven't had to
tell us what's wrong with him and they
won't until he's off of ir
and they get to a wednesday thursday
friday practice setting and they have to
issue a report saying whether to what
extended practice so we're going to be
in the dark for a lot of these guys and
and you're right
when i hear that so-and-so is on injured
reserve i think well he's screwed well
this is the year where it's like no but
no and and they don't care
if coaches stash players and you know
bill belichick is going to use it to
stash players this is all about having
maximum players available so if there's
a covet 19 outbreak they're not
scrambling for healthy bodies
and the 49ers made a number of moves at
quarterback today mike but nobody is
richard sherman i mean he he still is up
there uh among the top quarter
quarterbacks in the nfl but as you have
noted he's now not paid like one of the
top cornerbacks in the nfl he has an
eight million dollar base salary and and
i know you've dissected that a lot but
it was not a good contract for him and
he's going to lose an awful lot of money
this year for however long he stays on
injured reserve
yeah he can get to 13 and last year he
was very proud of the fact that he was
able to unlock extra payment because he
played most of the year he made it onto
the pro bowl roster he made it to second
team all pro which unlocked even more
money by missing just a few games this
year he's going to lose a million
dollars
in playing time incentive because he
needs to participate in at least 90
percent of the snaps on defense so
that's a million dollars gone a million
dollars for the pro bowl that's likely
gone if he misses three games i mean he
could come back and play incredibly well
and still make it who knows but that's
in jeopardy now and then two million
dollars to be first team or second team
all pro that's in danger as well that's
four million off the top plus 62 500 for
every game that he plays as a per game
roster bonus he's got five million
dollars tied up in incentives which
could get him to 13 or keep him at or
close to eight somewhere between eight
and nine based upon how many games he
plays
and
if he truly still is one of the best
corners in the game he's not getting
paid like it and just the question
becomes what's his future it's his last
year with the 49ers i think he may not
be back next year and who knows it's
hard for a guy to continue to play
corner for that long is he a guy who can
switch to safety that's something for
down the road but you know the 49ers
very banged up now shireen and i guess
the only good news out of today is
george kittle the star tight end wasn't
put on injured reserve which implies
that this knee sprain isn't going to
keep him out for three weeks
yeah that is good news for them and they
hope to get debo samuel back at some
point but you saw how much they missed a
healthy george kittle in the second half
he didn't have any catches and i don't
care what he said that he was fine you
could tell he wasn't fine in the second
half of that game and they certainly
missed debo samuel and there are other
receivers who are just banged up that
receiving core is just depleted right
now had to use raheem mozart and some of
those running backs
to make do through this game and and i
think that's part of the reason that
jimmy garoppolo i know he had over 100
passer rating and all that but he didn't
make the plays he needed to play
make
in that game and i think a big part of
that reason was the receiving core just
being depleted and not missing a healthy
george kittle in the second half and we
saw what the cardinals did and kyler
murray did with the healthy receiving
corps
that are really good receivers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports